الجميع يسعى لصحه عقليه افضل ولكن كيف
يمكن الوصول لهذا الهدف اطعام بانواعه
مفيد لذلك لان اختيار نظام متوازن يمنح
الفيتامينات مهمه لذلك على راسها فيتامين
بي خبيره التغذيه والطبيبه النفسيه في
جماعه
تؤكد على ضروره فيتامين بي في منع التدهور
المعرفي وحمايه الادمغه مع تقدم السن
مشيره الى اولوياته في الحفاظ على الدماغ
شابا وصحيا نعيده في حديثها الاخير الى
دراسه من كليه الطب جامعه وينست تؤكد ان
الاكتئاب والخرف والضعف العقلي غالبا ما
يرتبط بنقص فيتامين بي مؤكدا لان نقصى بيت
ويلز مثلا يعدوا سببا لمشاكل ادراكيه وهو
امر اكثر شيوعا خصوصا بين كبار السن الذين
يعيشون بمفردهم ولا ياكلون بشكل صحيح
نذهب الى العديد من انواع فيتامين بي
المفيده لصحه العقل واهمها
فيتامين بي وان او بي واحد وهو ضروري
لزياده الطاقه والتقويه الخلايا والمساعده
في استقلال عناصر الجسم خصوصا الدماء
وهو يعمل كمساعد للانزيمات في الخلايا
التي تقوم بتفاعلات مهمات كما هو الحال في
الجسم والدماغ فيتامين بي 3 ويسهل في
انتاج مواد مثل الدهون اللازمه للجسم
يساعد في تحويل الطاقه لجميع اعضاء الجسم
الذي يساعد في تفكيك الاحماض الدهنيه
للحصول على الطاقه
في الوقايه من الامراض لان المستويات
المناسبه من هذا الفيتامي مرتبطه بالخفاض
خطر الاصابه
[موسيقى]
على كل اللي استفيد اكثر ينضم الينا نورنا
في السجن دكتور طارق اختصاصي في التغذيه
السريريه والحمير دكتور يسعد صباحك نورنا
اليوم في الفيديو
هل بالفعل يمكن اعتبار الفيتامين بي بكل
انواعه هو الفيتامين الاول الصحه العقل
والشباب صباح الخير
في دعم الصحه العقليه وخصيصا كمان الاعصاب
لانه اكثر مشاكل بيصير عندنا انه نعرف
تاثير هذه الفائده من مثل بي والاستفاده
منه ولو حظنا كمان مثل ما ذكرته قبل شوي
مثل بي وان وبي 2 وركز على الانزايم
الانزيمات المهمه للجسم لتفكيك البروتينات
والدهون الموجوده لانتاج الطاقه
التوزيعها عن طريق بعض الاعصاب الموجوده
ما بين المعده والدماغ ونقل هذه الطاقه
الى الدماغ لاعطاء الطاقه له القيام
بنشاطه الاساسيه من فيتامين بي كمان عندنا
البي 9 والبي 12 الخاصين خصيصا
بالتركيز في قوه الاعصاب وزياده كريات
الدم البيضاء لنقل الاكسجين ونعرف احنا
الدماغ يحتاج الى كميه كبيره من الاكسجين
لنقلها فهو يساعد على تقويه الاعصاب
وتقويه صحه الدماء
100%
ارتباط المعده بالدماغ شيء اساسي خصوصا في
اخر ابحاث من عام 2014 الى عام 2018 اكتشف
وجود قنوات ما بين الدماغ والمعده تعمل
على نقل هذه التاثيرات الغذائيه اللي
بتصير عند الجسم في حال عدم تفكيك
البروتينات والدهون في الجسم مثل بسيط جدا
بعض المشاكل بيصير عند بعض الاطفال
السلوكيه مثل الايدي الجديد توحدما الى
ذلك اسباب كلياتها عدم هضم بروتين
الجلوتين وبروتين وهو بروتين القمح
ومشتقاته وبروتين الحليب ومشتقاته وهو ما
يؤدي الى تراكمات داخل الامعاء بما يعمل
مواد اشباه مورفينات تنتقل للدماغ وتعمل
على تاثير وعدم همم تاثير الطفل والانضباط
الى الطفل والكثير في السلوكيه
يعني نصها حتى نحصل الدماء على كميات من
الفيتامينات بي بكل انواعها اكل البيت اكل
البقوليات الخضره الورقيه الخضراء همم
بذور عباد الشمس وما الى ذلك هل بالفعل
يمكن التركيز على هذه الاغذيه ومتى تكون
المكملات الغذائيه هي الحل
يجب تركيزه على هذه المواد لانه كل
الفيتامينز له دور مهم جدا في تكسير هذه
الجزيئيات الموجوده بالاكل ونقل الى
الدماغ ولكن يوجد كمان فايته مساعد ثاني
مثل فيتامين دال بالنسبه للاكتئاب كمان في
عندنا المغنيسيوم معادن اخرى تساعد الجسم
في همم الحاله الصحيه والاستفاده من الصحه
العقليه انه يستفيد من هذه الفيتامين ولكن
بالنسبه للفايتامين بشكل عام فيتامين بي
يعمل همم هذه الماكولات تعمل على زياده
زياده افراز وتنظيم عمليات الانظام والهضم
في الجسم بالاضافه الى الاستفاده من همم
لكن نفسه انه يصل للدماغ بصحه ويكون افضل
له اني اسال عن طريق
المجريات القنوات الصحيحيه
طيب دكتور طارق ما هي النصائح التي يجب ان
امارسها انا وغيري لكي نحافظ على صحه عقلك
انا برجع للبطل الاسطوره ميسي الجميع
بيحكوا عنه هلا ميسي بال 2013 تبع اجمل
حميه غذائيه اللي هي الغد الحميه الغذائيه
النفسيه تتبعها مع الدكتور الايطالي وكان
هو السفير لانه احنا كمان لانه ما رسال
الحميه اللي هو الابتعادها للاكل الذي
يضره وعدم تحملها في بعض الناس عنده اكل
معين لما ياكله قبل عشر سنوات حاليا لما
يقلب بحيث انه يصير عنده طلبات اللي بحس
حاله نفسيه مش كويسه عنده انتفاخات عنده
وجع راس اذا هو يعرف الشخص متى صار الاكل
عدم تحمل ايده وهو لم يقدر ان احنا نعرف
انه هذا الاكل هل نستفيد منه او ما نستفيد
منه وهذا اللي عمله كمان ميسي اخر فتره
بحياته وانجازاته انه يغير النظام الغذائي
الكامل له وابتعد عن المشتقات الالمان
لانه كان يؤثر عليه وبعض المواد الغذائيه
كمان كانت تؤثر عليه حتى البروتينات واخذ
البدائل الصحيح وهو لان الاساس اخذ
البدائل الصحيحه في معرفه انه هذا الاكل
بطل يناسبنا واللي اخذ هذه فيتامينز عن
طريق الطبيب عن طريق الوصفات او عن طريق
الاكل البديل وهذا الشيخ يختلف من شخص الى
الثاني شكرا جزيلا دكتور طارق السيف
اختصاصي في التغذيه السريريه والحملات
العلاجيه